bonjour voici la suite de ma vidéo sur
les inventions imaginaire c'est à dire
les inventions qui n'existe pas mais qui
pourtant serait très pratique au
quotidien comme par exemple une vitre
électrique anti mecs qui parlent trop
près du visage
moi je suis un très grand fan de martin
scorsese primo la réalisation secundo il
ya un plan séquence d'une minute 47 et
là tu vois que c'est un truc de malade
donc tu parles dans le micro la
réalisateur je te disais de scorsese un
accélérateur d'histoire chiante et donc
l'entomologie si la science des insectes
et c'est vachement intéressant est ce
que tu as bien lu les petits poils sur
les papillons quand tu les caresses mais
tu sais pas c'est comme ça que je suis
devenu bouddhiste a d'abord passé par
histoire c'est cool et tu sais pourquoi
chez les bouddhistes
est ce que tu es déjà allé en anglais
les temps qui sont malnutris ont coûté
une machine pour tenir plus longtemps au
lit plus de deux secondes
voici continue pensez un pigeon mort
nazis tu tiens tellement longtemps
pensez y à du vomi dans la rue penser
alain juppé a rejeté solesmes là j'ai
plus envie à s'écouter page d'écouter un
détecteur de l'origine d'une mauvaise
odeur très pratique pour ces gens qui se
lâche sans pression en public
l'odeur de foot proviennent de c'est
comme ça il faut un anticipateur de
postillons en fermant furent une bd
super chouette ça s'appelle vaisseau
super spéciale et un moment il ya des
défauts ils se tirent dessus et ça fait
une montre qui permettrait de
disparaître dans les moments gênants
salek parce que cette digue de mer l'un
c'est l'autre groupe
je suis guitariste je suis chanteur un
transformateur de films chiants en film
cool
bon c'est déjà ça s'appelle la bo ne
faut pas fumer beaucoup dans les moments
on ne sait pas trop quoi répondre à
quelqu'un une télécommande qui
permettrait d'avoir une seconde chance
de répartie norman le youtuber le mec le
+ vidéo on à la retraite monsieur
maintenant je peux rentrer est contraire
je fais enfin plein de vidéos je ne
bougeais retraite ouais un peu comme des
cheveux bon là j'ai une tête de south
park parce que j'ai complètement oublié
de filmer ce plan avec la caméra et
ouais je suis je suis un peu con
l'invention suivante
ça serait un détecteur d'endroit où ça
gratte dans le dos alors grassement à
lahti tweet 16 et longitude 25 dit elle
une batterie d'iphone illimitée bon en
même temps ça existe ça s'appellera un
fils un wikipedia automatique dans le
cerveau qui l'a vu le pas
ah oui tu dire ce film réalisé par
francis ford coppola produit par les
studios paramount sortie le 15 mars 112
est inspiré du roman éponyme de mary
poteau bah ouais c'est ça tu en as pensé
quoi de pabu mais j'adorais un fouteur
de zone que t'as pas envie de regarder
si elles savaient que je vais flouter le
décolleté pour pas être tenté de le
regarder je vais passer pour un
gentleman
j'ai envie de me faire greffer des yeux
[ __ ] olala s'il savait que je l'a
entièrement flouté que j'entends même
pas ce qui dit qui est beau gosse à
adblock à blake pas marrante et tu
connais l'histoire de poteau 42e pas
c'est l'histoire des chinois d'un prêtre
et d'un boomerang
dix camions tir sur mon doigt ce serait
vraiment pratique pour les mecs pas
marrant ben hodges et ouais je disais
ouais nan en fait c'est pas une bonne
idée
un détecteur de potentiel de chance avec
les meufs alors elle 30% dans l 0% à ces
morts avec un mec à elle 90 % ok je me
lance est-ce que je vais pas te déranger
mais je vois que tu aimes les mêmes
chips que moi ça m'arrange je me suis
dit que tout ce qu'on pourrait les
comparer à boire un verre et ai parlé du
fait qu'on aime les mêmes chips et ou
pas il est tombé en fait
et enfin ce qui serait absolument génial
ce serait une invention qui lorsque vous
aimez la vidéo mais très directement à
pouce en l'air ça ça ce serait énorme
ou alors vous pouvez le faire à
l'ancienne
à bientôt
[Musique]
oui